c'est une histoire à peine croyable qui
s'est déroulée à Saint-Étienne le tueur
de l'un des plus puissants clans de la
mafia calabraise a été arrêtée suspecté
de demeure très en cavale depuis 17 ans
l'homme qui a changé de nom et qui était
devenu pizzaïolo à Saint-Étienne était
membre d'une célèbre organisation
mafieuse la mafia calabraise la plus
puissante au monde la redoutable drogue
Guetta le pizzaïolo recherché par
Interpol et condamné à la perpétuité a
pu être repéré et interpellé grâce à une
reconnaissance faciale après toutes ces
années vous savez personne n'est parfait
il a commis des erreurs retour sur cette
incroyable à faire ce soir dans TPMP
merci Michel
d'être avec nous grand reporter au
nouveau détective alors qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que c'est vrai que
tout le monde c'est intéressant à cette
affaire ce week-end je me suis dit c'est
un truc de fou alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé la mafia ça fait rêver surtout la
mafia qui a la braise c'est les vieilles
histoires
aussi
et la personne dont je vous parlais et
quelqu'un d'extrêmement dangereux
extrêmement violent mais uniquement dans
son cadre entre guillemets
professionnels mais ça je vais revenir
dans la vie italienne il s'appelait
Edgardo Greco 63 ans il est condamné
enfin il commet un double un double
meurtre à coup de barre de fer dans un
entrepôt de poissons et à plusieurs tu
deux membres de la mafia qui voulait
prendre de la mafiasse et ensuite tu
voulais prendre plus d'importance et
donc il y a eu un règlement de compte
intra mafiaque à la braise parce qu'il
des yeux de merlan frites
on a on n'a jamais retrouvé on n'a
jamais retrouvé les corps ah merde il
est également là on est en
janvier 1981 et en juillet 1991 pourtant
ça pourrait être pas rire
en juillet 91 il commet une tentative de
d'assassinat également merde
sans compter tout ce qu'il a fait et
pour les défaits ou pour lesquels il n'a
pas été poursuivi quoi qu'il en soit il
est dans le collimateur de la police
italienne il va être interpellé il va
s'évader pendant sa garde à vue du
commissariat donc en Italie tout ça en
Italie d'accord il est condamné à peu
près à la même époque un petit peu après
alors sans doute par contre humains
parce qu'il était déjà en cavale par la
Cour de d'assise alors je sais pas en
Italie si ça s'appelle comme ça mais en
tout cas une cour criminelle il est
condamné à la réclusion criminelle à
perpétuité et ça fait aujourd'hui 16 ans
qu'edgardo Greco vit en France en cavale
sous une fausse identité et dans la vie
française à Saint-Etienne il s'appelle
Paolo Dimitri trio d'accord alors
il a fait plusieurs oui toujours un peu
dans la restauration il était pizzaïolo
il a tenté de monter une entreprise il
avait donc des faux papiers des vrais
faux papiers a priori puisqu'il a réussi
à monter une société
il a réussi à acheter un fonds de
commerce c'est à lui la pizzeria pas
celle-là mais il avait acheté un fonds
de commerce il a eu un problème de santé
un cancer et du coup il a été obligé de
il avait pu la force physique et
peut-être un peu au bout du rouleau et
donc il avait revendu son son fond et il
vivait en toute tranquillité
jusqu'à et ça c'est son erreur cette
histoire c'est quoi c'est ce c'est ce
selfie c'est quoi c'est une photo il est
pris en photo on voit cette photo retour
derrière vous il est pris ça c'est en
2021 alors c'est dans une pizzeria
évidemment est-ce que c'est la sienne
est-ce que
aujourd'hui
derrière non celui-là oui ça aurait été
mieux que ce soit lui ça aurait été
mieux que ce soit celui qui est derrière
parce qu'on a pas reconnu on l'a vu et
donc on s'est dit ouais c'est le gars et
après il y a une enquête depuis 16 ans
et les les policiers italiens via
interpols le rechercher activement quand
même
quelle zone dans les mains
ça c'est l'erreur de sa vie et c'est
cette photo qui est publiée dans par nos
confrères du progrès en 2021 qui va
amener sa perte donc il a reconnaissance
faciale le temps que les polices
françaises et italiennes s'organisent ça
prend un petit peu de temps et ils
exercent une surveillance il s'agit
quand même de vérifier que c'est le bon
donc c'est ce qu'ils ont fait il y a eu
des certainement des plans qui est des
filatures et puis dans la nuit du 1er au
2 février ils l'ont interpellé en pleine
rue et en pleine nuit je crois qu'il
était 1h40 du matin et il a été placé en
garde à vue donc dans les dans les
locaux de la police française et il va
être probablement extradé puisqu'ils
italiens rechercher avec un mandat
d'arrêt international
en gros
bases de données avec ce logiciel de
reconnaissance faciale il reçoivent
toutes les photos parues dans le monde
entier notamment d'anciens de gens qui
portent des noms italiens et lui comme
son pseudo était italien ça leur est
acheminé et il voit appeler Guillaume
leducat et il voit qu'elle pourrait être
l'évolution physique de la personne et
ils en ont déduit que c'était bien lui
et deuxièmement comme il avait des
problèmes il avait des dettes
sans doute a-t-il fait appel à ses
anciens amis mafieux et pareil il
retrace des interdits
tous les mouvements donc c'est deux
données là on fait qu'il est tombé voilà
avec la police la retrouver c'est ça
Michel
depuis des années il y a une coopération
internationale qui est qui s'est mise en
place notamment avec l'Italie mais avec
beaucoup d'autres pays et les polices
européennes en tout cas et même des
autres continents collabore coopère dans
l'intérêt de du manifestation de la
vérité et alors ce qui est quand même
très étonnant cette dans cette histoire
et ça ça vaut le coup de le signaler je
pense en fait de le souligner
[Rires]
c'est que tous les gens qui l'ont
approché pendant sa cavale absolument
charmant
la pharmacienne
il était malade les gens pour qui il a
travaillé les gens qui ont travaillé
pour lui et pas dessus je ferai une
observation c'est que c'est ce type fait
partie d'une organisation criminelle
mais c'est un peu un métier ça me fait
penser à des vieux voyous qu'on avait
nous en France c'est j'en ai rencontré
certains à l'époque quand je faisais mon
quand j'ai fait mon bouquin c'était leur
métier c'est-à-dire qu'ils avaient femme
enfants les enfants allaient dans une
église enfin dans une une école
catholique ou religieuse tout était
bordé et puis
il changeait une heure après avoir
accompagné les gosses à l'école ils
partaient faire leurs affaires et là il
prenait des armes des gilets par balles
on peut considérer que c'est comme le
judoka avec le tatami et qui peut pas
exercer en dehors de sa circonscription
interne
[Rires]
en France il n'était pas dangereux parce
que c'est comme un judoka il ne combat
pas à l'extérieur la mise en
environnement
oui si vous voulez en tout cas
les amis
loin mais sur le fond bon je suis une
image qui est qui est pas oui